from the Alan's right side and so Anton
did his PhD in physics at the University
of Illinois originally coming in from
Russia and and then he did a postdoc in
the area molecular dynamics DP shop and
this led to his getting interested in
becoming involved in their sights it's
gonna tell us about kinds of datasets
that they've been watching also thank
you thank you very much Bruno and the
organizers for having me here thank you
everyone for coming it's very exciting
to see you here and thank you to the
previous speakers for the great start
they really did a wonderful introduction
I won't have to explain some of the
things that maybe I would have to and it
seems like everyone is interested in Big
Data and cool things that could be done
with new asan's data so well we have
some data at dar Land Institute and I'm
going to talk about three things today
first I'm going to give you an
introduction about the Allen Institute
itself about a little bit about the
history and different types of projects
that we do different types of data that
we produce and a lot of it is already
available or will be publicly available
soon the second part will be more about
what my team specifically does so I'm a
modeler at Allen Institute we have
several modelers actually a few of them
will be coming later in February and
March in April to spend a little time
here and they will tell you about their
approaches I will spend some part of the
talk here to talk about what my team
does which is about physically detailed
by physically detailed modeling of
neurons and networks and then finally I
have a few slides at the very end that
tell you about the ways how one can
access our data and the software tools
that we reproduce
uh producing to access this data and to
do some interesting science with it and
I hope it can be a call for action we
really want people to use our data to
have fun with it to make some
interesting discoveries with them and so
if we don't cover all of it please come
and talk to me I'm here until end of
Thursday I'm more than happy to talk
about everything in detail alright so
let's talk about the history of the
Allen Institute it was founded by Paul
Allen who is the co-founder of Microsoft
with Bill Gates this is this is just a
photo of the book that he recently wrote
an autobiography which I highly
recommend it's very entertaining and
exciting and you can learn about a lot
of cool ideas that he is passionate
about and one of them is science and
specifically the newest science so
obviously Paul Allen is a very rich
person and so he thought about ways how
he could spend some of this money to
advance search in a non-trivial way in
the field of brain science and so in
2003 he started our Institute which is
an independent nonprofit research
organization supporting basic research
in the brain sciences or we should
rather say also doing basic research in
the brain sciences and producing data
and we hope also knowledge to share with
the community so when this Institute was
started the aim was not to emulate what
works very well already which is the
university system the university system
is fantastic it advances creativity of
individual PI's it lets them flourish
and do a lot of very interesting science
which brought us very long way and will
probably continue bringing us a long way
from from now in terms of developing
advances in science so we are not trying
to replicate that we are not trying to
replace that or compete is that approach
what we are trying to do is to do
something that
that has been done already and has been
very successful for example in physics
and astronomy but hasn't been as much
used in neuroscience or biology in
general with some exceptions which is
the team approach to big projects that
cannot be done in individual labs so
think about particle accelerators or
telescopes which can be built only by
very very big coordinated teams and that
can be used by a huge number of
researchers around the world so the idea
was to create an institution that does
something along those lines and so
because of that we don't have individual
labs that that are independent we do
have labs like for example I'm a team
leader with a few scientists working
with me but these labs are not
independent there is a hierarchy at the
Institute and that labs are interaction
very tightly with each other there are
specific goals that each lab has to
contribute to and we are all trying to
work together to reach those aims so we
are focusing on a instead of a lot of
different projects that individual labs
can address we can really focus on a
handful of very large projects that can
be done and have to be done at scale and
that requires dieting directions across
different disciplines so in 2012 we
started a 10 year program so we are in
the middle of this ten year program it's
called project mind scope which is
focused on building cellular level
observatories in the mouse and human
cortex so even with you know what's the
amount of resources one has to focus on
something and our leadership decided to
focus on studying the cortex our model
system right now is the visual cortex of
the mouse because of the ease of genetic
access that one can have with the mouse
and then we also try to do some work
with the human cortex as conditions
permit so since its inception the Allen
Institute was most famous for the
datasets that it's produced these are
original these were atlases atlases of
gene expression so the very first one
was the Alen mouse and mouse brain
later on there was Alan human brain
Atlas connectivity mouse connectivity
Atlas so these are great resources and
some people here might have used them I
know that thousands and tens of
thousands people around the world have
used them but like I said after about
the first 10 years of this very
successful production of resources the
leadership decided that we want to do
something more and so this is where this
project started around 2012 and we had
our first data set from this project
already released so in 2015 we released
something that we called islet cell
types database and in 2016 something
that we called Island brain Observatory
and I'll tell you more details about
that later but the idea here is that now
instead of just looking at gene
expression and creating these huge
datasets we are systematically studying
the cortex we are trying to understand
what it consists of how things are
connected and how they behave in vivo
and build models of that as well and so
we generate data as well as knowledge
and we try to also make it accessible to
people so since the very beginning and
up to now and into the future of your
also it has always been that we make all
our data publicly accessible as soon as
they pass quality control
they are freely available without any
commercial restrictions and often they
accessible a few years prior to any
publication so we believe very strongly
that we shouldn't hold any data that
once once we convince that it's a high
quality data we will release it even if
we haven't had a chance ourselves to
fully analyze it yet and of course we
continue on in analysis on this data as
they're being released and of course we
publish papers and we like to to learn
something from our data as well not just
provided to the community but this
approach never failed us we were able to
to publish very high quality papers
using this approach but we also were
able to provide data very quickly to the
people and people use that very
extensively
so let me now talk about the various
projects that we have going on now with
this 10-year a 10-year effort that we
are in the middle of and I'm not going
to be able to talk about everything I'll
just focus on several large-scale
efforts and to do that probably it would
make sense to present it to you in a
hierarchical way so sort of how the
Institute is organized how the
activities organized is probably easier
to understand so basically the way the
Institute is organized now is that we
have three what we call programs and
different people belong to different
programs in the Institute one program is
called cell types and basically this is
the program which studies what the
cortex is made of the different cell
types how they're connected with each
other and most of that work is in vitro
work so work with tissue not in the
living animal the other program is
called brain TV and this is the program
that studies in vivo activity function
and computation of neurons in the living
brain it also includes modeling and
finally there is the program that's
called the product and this is these are
the people who package the data who
bring it all together
to serve it to the community and I will
not talk too much about this program it
would be way too technical but basically
everything that I'm going to cover all
the science eventually goes through this
very good people who prepare the data
and findings to be shared with everyone
so I'll focus on these two programs and
the first one is called cell types it's
by far the largest part of the Institute
and also probably the most mature has
produced in the last five or six years
some really interesting insights and
like I said it focuses on the
characteristics of seven connections so
Jeff has given us a very nice
introduction about you know the
different cells that one
finding the brain and the connectomics
and as you will see this program is
really about that about understanding
the diversity in the cortex and
understanding how things are connected
with each other and doing that in a
multi-modal approach with several
different methods that complement each
other so now we'll go through individual
projects within the cell types program
and the first one is transcriptomics so
essential tasks that one needs to
resolve if if one is to reach some kind
of understanding about what a piece of
the cortex does or build models is to
have a parts list you want to know what
the object is composed of well so we
know that there are neurons as Jeff
described there are different types of
neurons but exactly how many types are
there and then what they are and how are
they different from each other
another thing that one has to keep in
mind is that actually the answer to this
question belongs it depends on on how
what what exactly you want to know you
can think about it from many different
perspectives and the answer is going to
be different depending on what you want
to know exactly because different types
are going to be described in a different
way and they're going to to matter in a
different way one approach however to
look at that which is relatively
unambiguous is the transcriptomics so
what does make cells different in our
body like Jeff was saying there are
kidney cells and there are brain cells
right and there are maybe 15 different
types of kidney cells and there is who
knows how many types of neuron cells
what is different they all have the same
DNA well one thing that makes them
different is that ants kept Onix is how
different genes are being transcribed so
all the cells have exactly the same set
of genes in their DNA
but in different cells different genes
are being expressed
because of that that may not be the only
mechanism but because of that you get
kidney cells with one transcription
profile and brain cells with the other
transcription profile and then it goes
from there four different types of
kidney cells and four different types of
brain cells and those differences may
reflect the functional differences the
morphological differences the intrinsic
physiological differences of cells they
may reflect a lot of different things
some of which you may care about and
others you may not care about but in the
end this is a underlying underlying
mechanism and important mechanism that
different genes have been expressed
differently in different subjects and so
what we do here in this project we take
individual brain cells new ones but not
only neutrons actually Glee as well and
we we sequence their individual genomes
terms kept constant energy not very
importantly it's it's a RNA that we a
sequence in other DNA so so we sequence
the genes for those individual cells so
we know which genes are expressed in
each of those individual cells if we do
that for tens of thousands of cells and
then we can use different classification
methods to try to understand the
diversity of the cells and to try to
cluster them into the cell types so this
project is very well underway some of
the data is already available online
more will be coming some papers have
been published and just very briefly
I'll tell you some preliminary
conclusions that we have so for example
for the mouse visual cortex we believe
we reach the saturation so we now have
something like 20,000 cells for the
mouse visual cortex and we get about the
same number of types with that number of
cells as we do this twice smaller number
of cells so which tells us you know you
keep collecting the data but you don't
get anymore types we you are able to
assign you new cells to the types that
you've seen already does that mean that
we've sampled everything does that mean
that there are no very rare types that
we haven't seen yet no it doesn't mean
so but it probably means that we've
reached the level of suit
yes yeah there should be somewhere there
they day they actually mix very nicely
with this layer for in in terms of
transcriptomics they're not that
different
so yeah but what we get is about hundred
cell types for this a of the cortex of
the mouse cortex so I'm thinking like
fifteen hibbett area cell types and over
thirty excitatory cell types this is the
current picture we did the same for
another piece of the mouse cortex which
is frontal so the visual cortex is at
the back and there is an area called ALM
that we sampled which is in the front
and we get about the same number also
close to hundred cell types
interestingly the inhibitory cell types
are very very similar between these two
parts of the cortex whereas excited a
result types are quite different so you
know it would be interesting to look at
the parts of the cortex in-between to
see if there is maybe a gradient of cell
types of excitatory cell types across
the course and we also did the same for
human cortical pieces of human cortex
and for the human temporal cortex for
example it's a similar picture we get
about the same level of diversity with
you know over fifty and less than
hundred cell types about fourteen
hibbity over twenty excitatory the
numbers will go a little bit so it seems
like the level of diversities model is
the same between the mouse and the human
however there are specific types that we
get here are quite different we see some
that correspond to the mouse quite well
but a lot of them are different you know
there are whole genes that are present
in both a mouse and human brain and
might be a very good markers of whole
big classes for big groups of cell types
in the mouse but are not expressed in
the human brain at all so it's quite
fascinating you know the level of the
rest is similar but specifics might be
quite different
okay next project is now more about how
cell lukla cells look like and what they
do so ultimately we want to know
functionally what are the different
types in the brain what they do
in terms of how they process information
and that of course will be very much
dependent on how they're connected to
each other what kind of inputs they
receive from other parts of the brain
brain but also it will depend on the
intrinsic properties in the
electrophysiological properties and so
these and also the cell morphology in
other words how it looks like and
morphology is of course a proxy to what
the cells are connected to those are the
targets in this project so what we do
here is characterization of cells of
individual cells in vitro how is it done
we take a mouse brain fresh mouse brain
you slice it and then you record from
individual cells in this slices using
the technique called patch clamp
wholesale electrophysiology so it's a
little a glass pipette that you insert
into the cell body and then you can feel
the cell with the dye and then later
reconstruct its morphology and you also
can inject current into the cell and
record the voltage response of the cell
so that way you record different voltage
patterns in response to different
current injections and you characterize
the electrical properties of the cell so
we accumulate data for thousands of
cells this way we do that for the mouse
visual cortex as well as human human
cortex and this is really exciting
because not many places can do this we
now have relationships with several
brain surgeons in in Seattle who give us
these pieces of cortex that they remove
also Jeff described that they remove
when they for example have to treat
epilepsy so you will they have to get to
the center to depth a classic Center and
in the brain deep in the brain and on
the way there might be a little piece of
the cortex that they would have to
remove surgically and typically that
piece of quarter
has just been discarded as a medical
waste but in this case they actually
ship it to our Institute very quickly
and we can cut that up into slices and
do these recordings with this human
tissue which you know half an hour
before just had some memories of how
these people you know learn to ride the
bike or something and now we can record
from those exact cells so we accumulate
the data and again we pass it through
mathematical algorithms to obtain some
kind of classification very importantly
we try not to use expert judgment about
well you know this looks that way and
therefore I call you this type we try to
extract features about you know how this
Marc foliage is how tall they are how
wide they are how many branches they
have or features of the selected
physiological responses how fast the
firing of the cells is how tall the
spikes are and so on we extract those
features and requestor our cells on
those features and that way what we get
in this case this cluster so these are
just examples so we get about six sorry
six clusters for the the excitatory
cells and something like eleven for
inhibitory cells right now for the
electrophysiology and then for mythology
we get something like 30 for excitatory
and inhibitory together different cell
types and then if you think about that
if there is no relationship between
morphology in electrophysiology you
would get 20 times 3600 potential types
potential Electra morphological cell
types from this assessment but in this
data set we have both morphology and
electrophysiology from individual cells
and therefore we can actually answer
this question how many real electronic
illogical types are there and we see
that the overlap is much less morphology
is a good predictor of electrophysiology
and vice-versa and so in the end we get
about 80 Electra morphological cell
types so much less than 600 and
interestingly quite close to a hundred
that I mentioned before from
transcriptomics however our initial
studies suggest
that there is no one to one
correspondence between all
transcriptomic classes and Electra
morphological classes in a few cases
it's probably one to one in most cases
is going to be one to a few and want to
a few the other way and this is exactly
the subject of the next project where we
are trying to get all three modalities
at the same time so this technology is
called page seek is it's been developed
in couple of laps recently and we
learned from them we spent a couple
years trying to optimize this technology
and now it works very well and
essentially what's happening here is the
same experiment as I described before
where are you fill the cell with a dye
to be able to reconstruct this mythology
you record from the cell but then you
also extract its cytoplasm and the
nucleus and then you sequence the RNA in
that material that you extract from the
cell and that way you get both
transcriptome and electrophysiology and
morphology data from those cells so this
is this project is really just getting
started in our Institute we have some
interesting preliminary data but it's
relatively not not not as abundant yet
this project that I just talked about is
already has a lot of data available here
in this cell types database so I highly
recommend people to look at it all the
data free but eventually this table
modality data will be coming to that
same database as well potentially 600
different types and reduce them to 80
string method you're doing joint space
physiology yeah we tried that a little
bit but haven't had too much success
with that yet or maybe I would say that
that joint approach was was not as
convincing yet but what we have and what
works wearable is that we can do
electrophysiological clustering and
morphological clustering separately and
then which cell because we have both
electrophysiology and morphology we can
say which cluster belongs here and which
cluster belong to their right and then
we see that there are no there are no
not if you don't have cells that belong
to 600
combinations but it's a small
combination that they belong to you find
they correspond to things that people
have already talked about like well a
lot of them do yeah a lot of them do I I
would say we we see some finer
gradations and you know a little bit
more details but at a higher level it's
it does really recapitulate what has
been shown in the literature all right
so this is the part about the building
blocks now as we heard so beautifully in
previous talks an important thing that
really matters is connectome and there
are a few ways how we are trying to
address it and I'm going to illustrate a
couple of them for you so one approach
which is different from what was
described by the previous speaker
speakers is synaptic physiology so
instead of doing full electron
microscopy reconstruction what is being
done here multiple recordings recordings
from multiple cells at a time so you
know at the very least you would have
two cells occurred at four but in our
actual experiments we try to do up to 8
so it's octa-pie so we record from these
cells it's in slice and what you can do
is you can inject current in one of
those cells and produce spikes and then
the cells that that cell is connected to
the postsynaptic cells will show some
kind of response so if you happen to
record from a postsynaptic cell
you will infer that there is a
connection from the stimulated cell and
from the other cell that you record form
and then you know you can do that for
eight cells at a time so you can talk up
to 56 potential connections so what does
it give us it gives us the probability
of connection once you accumulated a lot
of data you can infer the probability of
connection but also something that for
example electron microscopy doesn't give
us this approach tells us the physiology
of connection it tells us the strength
of this connection and it tells us
dynamics of this connection kinetics of
this connection
things like potentiation for example
short-term we don't look at long-term
potentiation but short-term things which
which occur on the timescales of about
milliseconds to seconds where a for
example if you have a repeat train of
spikes the strength of the synapse can
actually increase that's called
facilitation or it can decrease which is
called short-term depression and these
things might be important for the
functioning of the network this is a
very laborious approach we now have I
think six rigs working in parallel which
is unprecedented and collecting this
data at a very high quality standardized
approach and what we are trying to do is
to map out a matrix of connections
between the different cell types now you
can say well you know if you have
hundred cell types you will have to fill
out a matrix with 10,000 elements and
that's too much even for us up to now so
instead what we are trying to do a tryin
to fill out a course matrix where every
lamp types together and we say well
maybe for single layer of the cortex you
have an excitatory cell type and a few
inhibitory cell types and then let's
look at the probability of connections
between them and then you get a matrix
that's more manageable on the 100
elements which is still a lot a lot of
data that's probably no single lab could
obtain and for which each each element
we are trying to collect something like
100 to 1,200 to 200 connections and in
the end we'll get this matrix which will
be obtained under standardized condition
very unique resource that will
eventually we'll be able to use for
models and for making conclusions about
how the cortex works and then another
approach which is very much along the
lines of what Jeff described and you
know in fact some of the activities in
this project in our Institute of Wonders
are the same so the same surface as some
of Jeff's work is to do electron
microscopy reconstructions so I don't
have to go into details it's very
similar the technology is slightly
different but the overall the overall
idea is similar and like some people
mentioned here the key for us is
actually to collect the physiological
data so
to a calcium imaging on a living
breathing animal first showing something
on the screen for this animal and
checking the responses of the cells in
the primary visual cortex of this animal
of the mouse so we get that information
about a lot of the cells in the cortex
on their activity and their preferences
in terms of the visual stimuli and then
we take that piece of tissue to the
electron microscope and then all the
same problems and joys that Jeff and
Neil described apply here and in the end
we hope that we'll be able to get again
you know beautiful connectome of up to
hundred thousand new ones with a lot of
cells I constructed with their mythology
so that we'll be able to actually know
which cell type they belong to and with
individual connections between them so
this is ongoing we've had some good
progress but you know it's probably at
least several years out there before
this will be complete and of course the
construction the automatic
reconstruction is a big problem we have
a collaboration with Sebastian Seung's
lab to work on that and we are focusing
this project on a one cubic millimeter
of tissue in the mouse V 1 and Q 2 cubic
millimeter of soft tissue in a human
cortex where of course we won't have
their in vivo physiology but where it
still will be extremely interesting to
see the connectivity all right so any
questions here
then I'll go to a different program now
so this is what we call brain TV just
for the sake of analogy between a TV
where you may have a millions of pixels
and brain where in the case of a mouse
cortex you would have millions of
neurons and when you record from just a
handful of them which is the current
state of affairs it's like watching a TV
with just a few pixels on and everything
else is dark and then try to understand
what is the movie that you are watching
on this TV so we were basically trying
to do a little bit better than that but
of course like everyone else it's a long
it's a long process so here the idea is
that this program is focusing on
networks on in vivo activity in the
animal under various conditions and a
big part of what we do here is also
modeling network modeling so let me tell
you about a couple big projects that are
going on in this program so one is what
we call visual coding this is the
project where we record activity from
living mice using two approaches one is
optical physiology using calcium imaging
you can characterize hundreds of neurons
at a time and we sample their responses
very systematically to a number of
different stimuli
you know such gratings that is a sort of
common stimulus in the field to map out
the responses of cells and also some
more naturalistic stimuli such as
natural images so natural movies so we
do it for a variety of cell types that
can be already now identified using
genetic tags at different depths in the
cortex and we put all of this data
online in this repository that we call
the alien brain Observatory then the
aspiration is that something that we are
working on now is besides optical
physiology we also going to do
electrical physiology using multi
electrode probes that will be inserted
simultaneously into several such areas
and will record so the depths of the
cortex we are using some very exciting
new technology called neural pixels
which will allow us to record from up to
thousand new ones
time and electrophysiology means high
temporal resolution this optical
physiology you get a big field of view
individual identified neurons in the
tissue but you don't have a high
temporal resolution you have a
resolution of maybe thirty Hertz whereas
with the electrophysiology you don't see
the neurons that you record from but you
can identify them just in terms of their
electrophysiological signature and you
can a quote from them with very high
temporal resolution with sub millisecond
resolution so that's that's coming up
it's not available online yet but we
hope to be able to release data in a
couple of years from now perhaps so you
know the pipeline here looks like this
we have a lot of several weeks where
mice you know I on a wheel they had
fixed on top of the mouse there is this
microscope that occurs the calcium in
calcium exhibits in the neurons and then
the mice are shown different visual
stimuli in this particular experiment
they don't have to do anything they can
run or they can stand still but they
don't do any behavioral tasks they just
look and and we sample their activity of
their neurons in the brain so the
database all the idea has information
for over 45,000 cells something like a
hundred different mice and it's growth
with more different cell lines coming in
and another thing where we are going
with this too is now doing something
that's more ideal towards the behavior
because ultimately what we all are
interested in is not just what's
happening in the cortex but how it
relates to behavior how the sensory
information that comes in into visual
cortex is being distributed as being
processed in other parts of the cortex
how the decisions have been made the
decisions that allow animal to perform
some tasks and eventually to survive and
so on to that end we've developed a
change of detection behavioral tasks
where a mouse on a wheel it's it's
running and on the computer monitor its
seeing some images it can be
images like this great alcoa can be
natural images can be some other objects
and it has to report a change so for
example imagine that this sort of image
is flashing and then at some point it
changes the orientation and then the
mouse if it's tainted knows that that's
that that's what it has to report and
reports it by licking for a reward so
and then as the mouse does it we use the
same approach as I just described before
where we record from hundreds of neurons
in different parts of the cortex or we
use electrophysiology either using
electric electrophysiology or optical
physiology so we've tested out this we
created a pipeline to do that in
parallel for for several animals at a
time and this year we'll be trying to
put a trailer online start collecting
the data in a high school put manner to
be also made publicly available
eventually if the mouse is looking at
different parts of the screen maybe the
the data and one file would be very
similar to data on another table because
the actual input to a particular part of
the cortex might be so mice don't have
phobia however they do move their eyes
and so absolutely you know if on one
moment the mouse looks that way and the
other move and it looks and slightly off
then you cannot compare it directly but
there are approaches to deal with that
so for example now on all our recordings
like this we have eye tracking software
which in principle will allow us to
disambiguate exactly where the mouse is
looking at and you know how to map the
image on the retina okay so this is
basically all that I wanted to say about
the different experimental approaches so
now let me talk a little bit about
modeling well first of all I mentioned
something sort of from a high high level
and then go more into details on some of
the specific model and activities so
most of the people are dialing istituto
experimentalists and we I think
we're really good at putting together
this very big pipeline and create and
date and eventually serving the data to
the community but we also want to
analyze the data and ultimately to build
models with this data to make some
predictions and so we have several teams
of modelers who work at different levels
of resolution and essentially it breaks
down into two directions of work
modeling wise we have models of vivan so
just one cortical area in the mouse
which which we which we study with many
different methods a lot of the different
methods of experimental methods that I
described to you before they actually
focus on we one for example for example
electron microscopy reconstruction
it focuses on v1 so this is just you
know a big area something to focus on
one can say well the hypothesis there is
a some kind of canonical network
canonical circuit so let's try to
understand that in v1 and maybe that
will help us to understand what's going
what's going on in other areas too so in
this direction we employ a couple of
different approaches by physically
detailed models and point neuron models
to build this quite detailed models of
v1 something like 200,000 cells which is
actually more than half of all v1 with
all layers painting from layers one down
to layer six and then the other the
other direction of modeling were cortex
models where we are trying to do more
simplified approaches using point neuron
and neural network type machine
intelligence approaches to build simpler
less computationally expensive models of
multiple cortical areas focusing on
several visual and potentially a number
of non visual areas and eventually what
we work on to that end is to try to
connect those models with the behavior
in the animal because especially for the
behavior it's it's very unlikely that we
one is sufficient to explain it you
really have to go for multiple visual
areas and then not visual areas as well
so my colleagues who will be here in the
subsequent months probably will tell you
more about these approaches
some of these as well my own team is
focusing here with the data-driven
approach and very detailed very
computationally expensive modeling of
the v1 circuit and that's what I'm going
to be talking about next so before going
there are there any questions
all right now all right
so let's talk about modeling then just
like with the experiments before
building a model of a circuit you need
some building blocks and our building
blocks ourselves neurons as I told you
we have this database of cells for
individual cells that are characterized
with their morphology say constructed
and their electrophysiological
properties recorded so what we are
trying to do here is now to build a
parallel database of models of those
individual cells which can then be used
as building blocks for networks so we
actually follow a few different
approaches here where we combine
morphology of a cell with its
electrophysiological recordings to build
models at a number of different levels
of abstraction so so there were a couple
of compartmental by physically detailed
model types that we use in some of them
the nonlinear conductances which really
underlie the computational properties of
neurons I distributed all over this
dendrites and the soma and this is this
away expensive models also somewhat
unconstrained because all our recordings
are from the soma so we really don't
have such a good picture of what's
happening in the dendrites
even do we know that there are a lot of
nonlinear is occurring in dependence
what my team is working on and this is
the approach that that will be used in
all subsequent slides is some kind of
middle ground where we still use
compartments and we still use
distributed morphological structure of
the neuron to provide diversity of
synaptic inputs but we try to make a
simplification and say well all
nonlinear processes are hope happen in
the soma and so that makes the model
much more computationally tractable and
then there is another set of approaches
where we use this very simple law point
new and generalized sleeking integrate
and fire models that you will probably
hear later in later months from one of
my colleagues which ignore the
morphology altogether and only look at
spike in activity of the cells so we've
developed a number of optimization
methods to take individual cells take a
morphology of this cell take the
electrophysiological recordings and soon
our nonlinearities in the model so that
the model does more or less the same
thing as the cell that's been following
the footsteps of some of the other
research labs which however typically
focused on trying to reproduce some kind
of a cell type behavior so we're a
relatively abstract abstract modeling
exercise whereas here we try to do it
really consistently for individual cells
and we've just got two papers accepted
in Nature communications they will be
coming out very soon one is about
optimizing such models for by physically
detailed approach and point neuron
approach and they also report the
algorithm and the algorithm is released
anyone can now use it to optimize their
own models from such recordings so
basically what we show is that this
method is is working pretty well in the
case of by physically detailed model
it's using a genetic optimization
approach using basically off the shelf
tools from genetic optimization in
Python and it generalizes pretty well to
a number of different cell types to
first spike in internal ones to regular
spiking into neurons to small excited
results to big excitatory cells to
really huge excitatory cells in layer
five so we've shown that we can model
most of them pretty well and so now in
the database in this data is actually
online the models are now online anyone
can use them we have close to 200 cells
for which you have morphology
electrophysiology and models of a
we also showed that same methods work
pretty well for human neurons even do
they're quite different from mouse
neurons they are much bigger some people
say that their intrinsic parameters are
very different but we found that our
methods can reproduce the electrical
behavior of those cells pretty well -
given the morphology and experimental
recordings and so now we have 43 cells
human new ones for which we have by
physical models also available online
just at the cell body so we have the
full map followed represented in the
model however there are a couple
different methods and in some methods we
assume some non lane nonlinearities in
the dendrites in this particular case we
actually assume that only non-linearity
is happening at the soma all right so
now we have the building blocks and we
use those building blocks to build
Network models and now what I'm going to
tell you is a story where we started
from
you know the whole we want the whole
cortex has several layers it's a lot of
cells it's a lot of complexity so we
started from something simpler and we
wanted to simulate just one layer of the
cortex layer 4 of v1 of a v1 in the
mouse layer 4 is where most of the
primary obstacle or visual inputs are
coming to in the array v1 and so that's
why we've been focusing on it at this
stage as a first step in information
processing in the cortex so I'll tell
you how we did this for the layer 4 I'll
tell you some of the stories about what
we try to learn and how what we found
with the idea that this is sort of the
thing that we want to repeat for the
full v1 circuit once we have it built ok
so what do we do here we first had to
decide what is it that we have to model
we know that we want to model
than a single new one we want to model a
network but how much and for that
purpose we looked at approximate radius
of connectivity so what is you know if
you look at an individual neuron it's
probability of connection to other
neurons goes down with distance and so
the the lens constant in that dependence
in that functional dependence of
operability of connection is a few
hundred microns so in the end we decided
that we'll model something like 400
micron radius disk so this is this is
sort of looking down on the surface of
the cortex this is the back of the head
of the mouse these are the different
cortical areas and this is how the v1
looks like and then what we are trying
to model is just the middle portion of
it here right and so that comes comes
down to about 10,000 neurons so here's
our 10,000 neurons that we positioned
here in this circle they all come from
the early version of our island cell
tides database where we had just a few
good models several years ago to work
with now we have much more but at that
point that was just a few and so we just
took them and they replicated many many
times and that's how we populated this
this piece here then when you do that
you realize that there is a problem the
neurons at the center of this area that
you are modeling are going to be well
connected with their partners but the
neurons at the edge are going to be
about half as connected so you know it's
like they have a lot of partners to
connect with here but on this side it's
emptiness and so to do with this
boundary conditions one could in
principle use periodic boundary
conditions but we found the number of
bad artifacts if one does that and so
instead what we did we basically did a
hybrid model we introduced another
another set of cells here which we model
that much level much much lower level of
resolution so instead of by physically
detailed we now use point neuron
approach here which is much much cheaper
but that at least gives some partners
for these cells for this biophysical
cells here to connect with and so now we
don't have this big disparity between
cells in the center and
the edge that proved to be not too much
additional computational expense but you
know helped us to resolve this boundary
artifact good question so ultimately we
want to use the data that are coming
from our own experiments along the lines
of what I told you several slides ago
from synaptic physiology from electron
microscopy which would be really really
exciting we haven't had it at that point
we still don't quite have it now even
and so what we try to do we try to
follow the literature data in the
literature sparse and you know taken
from different animals and under
different conditions so you really have
to take it with a grain of salt but it
does constrain your model it tells you
you know there is probably probability
of connection that goes down with
distance
it's different for excited day between
hibbett area versus inhibitory to
inhibit reversal inhibitory or
excitatory and so we were able to make
some basically guesstimate destinies
based on literature and constraint our
model that way so there is a number of
papers that we used for that purpose
yeah so very good question so you know
we did that it's probably not ideal but
it's the best that we could do at this
point and once we have the more full
array of data we will certainly replace
it with the real data okay and then now
I haven't told you the purpose of this
model yet I mean there can be many
purposes altom utley what we want to do
we want to do some kind of a platform
for discovery where if the model is
sophisticated enough if we show that
that we can believe it enough for some
things that we can test we can try
perturb instincts in the model and maybe
coming up tasting some hypotheses in the
model which will then help us to drive
new experiments and then test those
hypotheses in the experiments but to
start with you actually need to create
that platform you need to test that you
need to compare it with the experiment
and what the experiments we want to
compare it with we want to compare it
with the experiments in the living
animal it's it's not enough for us to
say well you know we connect it
according to how it is in the slice and
it produces some kind of activity we
need to compare to what happens in the
actual brain
when they animal is alive and for that
purpose we have amazing datasets just
the ones that I told you few slides ago
where we record from this living animals
right with different approaches so
that's what exactly what we wanted to do
we wanted to show movies visual stimuli
to our model and to compare statistics
of neural responses from the model to
those from the experiments but to show
the movies or to see the movies you need
the eyes this model doesn't have the
eyes so in the real mouse what happens
is that you have the retina which then
sends the signals to a nucleus called
lateral geniculate nucleus of the
thalamus and that projects to the
primary visual cortex especially to the
layer form this is a lot of complexity
and we didn't have the data and we
didn't have the bandwidth to really try
to model it in a very sophisticated way
so we try to use an approximation we've
created a model that sends inputs to our
biophysical model and that's a model of
Ptolemaic inputs that's basically
replacing this whole pathway the retina
and the thalamus by very simple filter
models so this filter models now operate
in the visual space you show it a movie
a particular filter has a temporal
component a special component that
focuses on certain part of the visual
space a different filter will focus on a
different part of the visual space it
has certain temporal dynamics and
basically it processes that that piece
of movie that it cares about and and the
output it gives you a firing rate
time-dependent firing rate that can be
turned into spikes and those spikes can
be fed into our with one model so a few
things to note here one is that to
parameterize these filters we had the
experimental data with
electrophysiological recordings from the
thalamus
but those data show that there is
actually a variety of cells of cell
types in the thalamus some respond
quickly to the stimuli other responds
respond more in a more sustained way and
we didn't feel like we had the bandwidth
to model all of that at that point yet
so we just modeled three very common
types that we found in those recordings
does that respond to light does it
respond to dark and does that respond to
boss in a transient way so this is very
important for the later one in a tangent
way so once something comes down on the
screen it's a quick response and then
the cell is silent again and then
another important thing is how the cells
connect to the v1 model and that we
really don't know this is a big mystery
although there are hypotheses and one is
the one that I think Jeff mentioned us
who build a visual model which is like
60 years old but basically it says that
there is some evidence for it in the
literature basically it says that you
know cells that prefer the that respond
to the dark stimuli and cells that
respond to the bright stimuli they bunch
together in the visual space and so
there would be a such sub field that
that responds to dark and another circle
that responds to bright and then they
have to be offset with respect to each
other a little bit and that actually
that way you can get certain important
characteristics of neuronal responses
for example orientation selectivity so
this will be very important further on
orientation selectivity is a fundamental
property that you observe in cortical
neurons for example in v1 which is the
following if you show some kind of
moving object this cell will respond
strongly to a particular direction
orientation of this motion so for
example certain cells would respond
strongly when you have horizontal motion
but don't respond almost at all when you
have vertical motion so those cells are
called orientationally selective
furthermore you find cells that that
like a particular direction so it may
respond strongly in this direction but
not so much in the opposite direction
that's called Direction selectivity
orientation selectivity and Direction
selectivity so what we need to realize
here is that this architecture gives you
an impatient selectivity but not
Direction selectivity this is a
feed-forward input and then after this
this information comes to our model
there is something that's happening with
the recurrent
action inside of the model itself that
processes that information further and
we will look at it in a moment okay so
we've set up the model you start
simulating the model and then you get
something like this and this is
basically what happens in epilepsy so
this is our time and this is our new
runs and this is what is called spike
raster which is whenever a cell fires
produces a spike you have a dot here so
this is 10,000 cells at the core of our
model firing away in response to some
visual stimulus but as you can see here
one cells start firing they start firing
altogether and then because of
inhibition they quickly shut down and
you just have these waves of activity
when the system is active all at the
same time or it's silent always at the
same time it's epilepsy essentially
that's what happening at the labs and
that's not how the cortex works why it's
happening it's because our synaptic
weights are not optimized we've got them
from the literature literature very
disparate the you know there is a
difference between in vitro and in vivo
there is a big range of of the values
that you get from the literature and so
you actually have to optimize this model
this is very expensive model to optimize
but we did it mostly manually and then
the aim for optimization was to get
something like this where you have a
much more desynchronized activity and
also we wanted to match the spontaneous
rate that's known from the experiments
in other words what the system does when
you show nothing on the screen just the
gray screen and the peak firing rates
for grazing so it drifted great and
something like that moving on the screen
you want to get firing rates that are
consistent with the experiment so that's
a very very limited training set and I
just want to impress on you the idea
that this is a very complex model but
it's far far far from the complexity of
the real brain it's actually very very
simple in comparison with the real brain
and it's been trained on a very very
impoverished data set on essentially a
single episode of such adrift in grading
for half a second
so it includes only direct current
connections within layer 4 itself yeah
it doesn't have anything else it does
have some kind of additional source of
inputs which we call background which is
basically representing everything else
very very simple extremely simple and
trained on a very impoverished data set
and then once we trained that we just
throw this whole battery of stimuli that
we take you know we couldn't do
everything but we take a number of
different types of stimuli from our
brain Observatory paradigm and we just
throw it at the model we run a lot of
simulations with a lot of repeats you
know very very expensive and in the end
we get something like 3600 simulations
that we can analyze in detail and
compare with the similar with the
experiments so let's now look at how it
compares you know this extremely simple
model which also has been trained on a
pretty small data set and tested on a
very big data set so first quickly look
at how the responses look like well
these are just some examples of
different of different types of stimuli
so this is a different grating this
pattern of black and white moving on the
screen as you can see when the gradient
comes on a lot of activity happening so
these are cells they are sorted
according to their responses to this
grating some of them real like this
grating the light they defy a lot and
others don't so they almost don't fire
at all then if you do this for gratings
that move in different orientations and
you sample that with multiple trials you
can build such Union curves for
individual cells and you see that this
cell for example this is an excitatory
cell it really likes 0 in 90 degrees
sorry zero and hundred eighty degrees
and it doesn't like 90 degrees and 270
degrees so it's a classical
orientationally selective cell it likes
this orientation of motion but not this
but it's not a directionally selective
so it doesn't care whether the motion is
in this way point that way so just an
example then if you have a flash a full
field flash where the screen was gray
and and it turned white and then gray
again this is how it looks like so
different and then if you have for
example a natural movie with some
objects and people moving in the screen
you see yet a different type of response
and here interestingly you have these
groups of cells respond together and
that's basically reflection of an object
or person moving so that through that
field of view in a particular
orientation where a cells that like that
orientation will fire together now if
you take that movie and you scramble it
in time you don't have that anymore you
have these bands of activity which due
to the due to the background excitation
but you don't have this coherent
activity yes well it's just one layer it
is just one layer there are there are
three excitatory and to inhibitory cell
types in this model and within type they
are sorted according to their
orientation preference they are the same
on all the spots yes yeah so that's
exactly the question and ultimately this
is the question or did you know that the
performance will depend on the question
that you ask and what you are interested
in and there is no universal benchmark
that you could do so what we try to do
we try to develop such a benchmark
looking at a number of things that have
been observed in the cortex and those
that people can see they're important
and you know study a lot and so I just
show you a few and tell you how we are
doing so one case is that one of the
duration is that responses in the cortex
log normally distributed
so approximately log normally
distributed so if you if you look at all
your cells in a single trial of a single
stimulus and you just plot a
distribution of their firing rates you
find that it's not like all cells fire
let's say between you know 3 and
five Hertz it's not like that it's
actually log normally distributed it
distributed over a few decades over a
few orders of magnitude and this is an
important thing which not every model
can match actually we found that in our
model that's the case and and the
distribution spends two to three orders
of magnitude and that's consistent with
the experiment then we looked at some
other properties for example spontaneous
rate or the maximal rate in response to
gratings and that can be computed for
every cell and then you can do such box
plots where the black black marks are
just the mean and you can compare it
with the actual electrophysiological
measurements from the experiment which I
integrate here and so you see it's not
one-to-one but it's sort of in the
ballpark so spontaneous rates alike
between you know 0.5 and 1 Hertz on
average consistent with the experiment
were maximum firing rates for excitatory
cells are very much consistent with the
experiment at 6 to 8 Hertz for the most
visual cortex layer for our inhibitory
cells a little too high in comparison
with our all measurements but a more
consistent with something else published
in the literature so sort of in the
ballpark now this important properties
of orientation selectivity and Direction
selectivity so this is something that
can be characterized by this index
called orientation selectivity index and
Direction selectivity index for
orientation selectivity if a cell likes
this orientation and doesn't care at all
about this orientation the orientation
selectivity index going to be 1 and if
the cell fires exactly the same
magnitude for all Aryan tation is going
to be zero so for real cells in the
layer 4 you find that the orientation
selectivity index on average is about
0.5 and this is what we did for
excitatory cells as well so this was a
very good match we didn't tune the model
for that we got it out of the model sort
of naturally now we were very happy
about that and how does that happen it
happens because we provide these inputs
we provide that orientation and
selective
inputs from the thalamus which are then
amplified by recurrent
connectivity within the layer itself
actually we can repeat this experiment
without a current connectivity and we
will see them the disorientation
selectivity index will be somewhere here
so the recurrent connections are really
important in this model but then the
direction selectivity index which
basically tells you you know if the cell
likes this direction of motion but
doesn't fire a lot in the opposite
direction then the direction selectivity
index one if it fires the same way in
both directions at zero in real layer
four this index is 0.5 in our case it's
zero so the model utterly fails on this
particular observation but we think we
know why and this is exactly it has to
do with this filters that I introduced
earlier which are basically all the
ancient they quickly respond when a
stimulus comes on and then they shut
down so there has been some recent
research and papers probably going to be
published soon suggesting that how this
works and in the mouse is that the
thalamic projections 2v1 actually need
to be both ancient and sustained to
build direction selectivity and we've
now developed a new model like this
where we have more cell types that are
more representative of what's going on
in the thalamus and where we can
actually recapitulate direction
selectivity at least in the feed-forward
regime so you know this is an example of
where you learn by doing we didn't
expect our model to work so well for
some other things but you know if we
also didn't expect it to necessarily
fail but it failed miserably here and
this is where you go and change your
model and do it make it better so a
couple more observations here in the
actual mouse recordings you find that
things are synchronous they are not
completely synchronous but there are
some kind of oscillations population
activity level oscillations that are
going on where cells often respond sort
of to stimuli within a certain rhythm
and the reason that you often find in
vivo on
what is called Mouse gum written at
about 25 Hertz so we took a power
spectrum of our activity in the model
and we saw a peak at around 20 Hertz
it's not exactly 25 but at the same time
the model like I told you is very
simplified and so it was quite
satisfying to see that there is this
sort of gamma oscillations present and
finally just another comparison there is
something that's called sparsity of
responses so if you think about a movie
let's say a cell just fires all the time
during a movie that means there is the
response of the cell to this movie is
not spiced and then this the scene takes
this lifetime sparsity will be zero and
then another cell might respond to only
a one particular frame of that movie so
it's very spicy sports and then the
syndics is going to be one and then you
can have values in between so then what
you can do you can get your cells and
get a distribution of the sparsity
values for different cells and you can
ask well how does it look for natural
movies versus for example distant
ratings and what you see in both
simulation and experiment even though
exact distributions are different you
see the trend that the natural movies
the responses to natural movies are
sparser there are more sparse than two
gratings so this is something that we
observe in the model is consistent with
the experiment they mean well you are
actually also quite close and this has
been shown also previously with other
recordings so this is also an important
observation in terms of how the model
behaves with different types of stimuli
so just a couple of other things now you
know that was sort of a benchmark with
the benchmark you can say well how well
the model corresponds to the reality but
now we also want to ask some questions
about mechanisms question here just a
small question of so you trained the
model
beginning as well right so do you how do
you divide out what you trade the model
to do kind of you know what I mean I
mean if you trained it to risk like you
feed it some data and some expected
results in a sense oh yeah well so that
basically had to be done here by
necessity just because training the
model is so difficult and
computationally expensive and so we had
to limit ourselves to wait a small
training set the training set was just
one episode of a drift integration in
one direction so you know you can do
this drift in gratings and multiple
directions and you can do multiple
trials so we just took one trial of one
grazing direction in one direction that
was our training set plus spontaneous
activity that's that's all and then the
test set is on a whole battery of
different stimuli like this in addition
there was all this data that came into
building the model from the bottom-up
approach but there we didn't really have
much liberty to tweak that
okay and so now just couple words about
some things that one can learn from this
model so one is that you know well there
are inputs that coming into this model
from the thalamus and then there are all
these connections within the layer for
that do something else and the question
is how much of excitation comes from the
thalamus related to this recurrent
activity related to the total and so you
can compute that number and you can
build the distribution for different
cells and turns out that in our model
it's about 40 percent so about 40
percent of excitation comes from the
thalamus and everything else is due to
the recurrent connections well turns out
that this is actually very consistent
with the experiment this has been
measured just a few years ago and very
very close number we didn't build the
model to get this but the model
basically gives us this very nice number
by itself and then this is just one
example of what we try to do with the
model now sort of trying to learn
something and ultimately this is really
where we want to go to make predictions
to make to tell something about the role
of cell types or about the role of
particular patterns of connections that
could be tested experimentally this is
where we go thus far it's relatively
minor but you know just just to give you
a taste of how things are so this is
something that's called like - like
connectivity so we took heard a lot
about connectivity today we know that
different cell types connect with
different probabilities but it turns out
that there are also all this additional
rules that people start observing and in
the lair to see so not in the lair for
but in the lair 2/3 of the mouse visual
cortex people observe the following rule
that excitatory cells that prefer
similar stimuli have a higher
probability of connection with each
other and stronger synapses and in a way
it's very natural there is this hebbian
you know
rule that says that that cells that fire
together wire together so it could be
expected but it hasn't been observed
before until these few experiments and
some experiments from clay Reed slab who
is now a dull and Institute use an
electron microscopy by the way
combination of
physiology in a living animal and
electron microscopy so we wanted to test
this rule and actually the whole model
that I described to you before was
implemented using exactly the soul and
then we try to tweak the soul so with
this will like to like connectivity so
the cells that prefer that's a similar
orientation of motion will have higher
chance of being connected to each other
and stronger synapses so like to like we
get this distribution of orientation
selectivity indices and you can see that
it's a high-value consistent with
experiment something like point five on
average and then on the other end of
spectrum what we tested was the random
connectivity so now instead of the cells
that that like the same stimuli they
don't have any preference in terms of
being connected with each other and you
see that that destroys orientation
selectivity completely this is now this
black profile and then there are cases
in between where there is the
permeability of connection or synaptic
weights follow this this like to like
important and so you know again this is
this may not be very surprising because
of course if cells that prefer similar
stimuli fire together you will have sort
of reinforcements here whereas here it
will be randomization so that could be
expected but we really couldn't say for
sure before we tested it in this model
the fact that the model is consistent
with a lot of experimental observation
gives some weight to this prediction and
this hasn't been observed yet in the
lair for this whole has been observed in
the layer two three but it hasn't been
observed in the layer four and so the
model tells you that this is what you
should expect in the layer four of the
mouse we want and by the way this is
what it's good for it's good for tuning
for producing tuning of cells in
response to stimuli
finally on the model inside this is the
last result slide one can ask a question
so this was a very detailed by physical
very computationally expensive model is
it is it stupid to use such an expensive
model to simulate can can we get away
with something simpler and so we try to
answer this question we developed two
additional models where we took all this
by physical cells and replace them by
point neurons very simple
computationally inexpensive
approximations in one case both are
implemented in the software called
neuron in one case it's a very simple
leak integrate and fire new one with
instantaneous synapses in the other case
there is actually some kind of time
kinetics that's also associated with
synopsis and we tried to optimize these
models and check how they perform in
comparison with the biophysical one and
so what we found is that you know in a
sort of large scheme of things the
models perform similarly to each other
so they they all are sort of in the
ballpark you know some quantitative
differences but overall similar firing
rates similar orientation selectivity in
this is although for this model for
example in fire one we really couldn't
get lower orientation selectivity which
would be more consistent with the
experiment was to orientation only
selectively and then similar trends with
respect to this like - like connectivity
rules that I told you about although
again qualitatively is the same
quantitatively not quite so the the the
simplified model for example it has a
little to hire intuition selectivity and
even when you destroy it by randomizing
the connections it's still a little too
high and then things like you know
sparsity in response to great election
movies the trains
trends are the same between biophysical
and point human models but the point
neural models for example have way too
high sparsity for the natural movies and
finally the oscillations the gamma
oscillations
they are totally absent in the entire
one model and in this slide
more sophisticated in fire for model we
start picking up some oscillation in
about at about 16 Hertz so somewhat
consistent with by physical case but
still not as good and this is probably
due to this synoptic time constant
that's present in this model and not in
this model which which is something that
people showed many times before
so in conclusion basically what should
they say I cannot say that you cannot
use these cheaper point Newman models to
simulate carriage cortex you can it just
depends on the question that you are
after
if you after qualitative trends I think
you'll be fine if you want to be more
quantitative it depends and I cannot
claim that there are no simpler models
that can do better than this is just to
that we tried but we do see some
quantitative differences and the
biophysical seems to be a little bit
better consistent with the experiment
all right so where are we going from
that now well basically we are building
a bigger model we are done with the
layer four now we are building all the
Romanian layers it's the same idea but
now with all the layers down from from
layer 1 down to layer 6 this model has
about 50,000 by physical cells 230,000
cells in total
something like 114 unique models from
our database and you know a lot of
different cell types under those 20 cell
types now so is this model will be able
to start tasting some additional
interesting questions like potentially
role of particular cell types in this
whole in the context of this whole
circuit and now I just want to go
quickly through a few slides with a sort
of a call to action if you are
interested in the data that I presented
to you and in the models that we are
developing it's out there for you to try
and I'm happy to discuss offline details
but basically these are our websites you
go to this website you can get all the
data that we have including the cell
types database and brain Observatory
model there is the github site with the
thing that's called Allen software
development kit so these websites they
let you interact with the data online
very nicely but
if you want to do something serious with
them this software gives you the handle
to do that to interact with the data to
download data in an efficient way and to
also analyze the data at least start
analyzing the data
Allen brain Observatory contains you
know many thousands of neurons that can
be analyzed real in vivo responses to
visual stimuli and a very exciting
development that we are working on we
hope will come online maybe in the next
year or two is that we will open this up
to the community so that people will be
able to submit their experiments and to
basically it will be like a grant
competition there will be submissions
where people would suggest experiments
that they want to do given our
instrumentation and we will do that for
them sort of astronomy telescope mode
where people ask for certain time on
telescope pointed to this star and get
the data back and we'll try to do a
similar similar thing and then also I'll
talk about so that database already we
have workshops there is this workshop
that we do every summer now in Friday
Harbor lab it's a marine biology lab of
University of Washington in a beautiful
rustic place on an isolated island you
know about 25 students work together
there's there is at least one who was
there before I think they enjoy it very
much
you know working very late in the night
with laptops and with teaching us
assistance from the Institute helping
them out and so the cool thing is that
now starting from last year we make this
course materials available online so
anyone can go here on this github page
and look at the course materials and it
will again give you the same tools that
I showed you a few slides ago now with
the specific applications and sort of
more didactic way to get introduction to
the data and to handle on the data so I
really highly recommend this it's it's
very exciting and once you once you do
those exercises you will have much
better familiarity with the data
and finally we've also developed the
developed software for modeling which we
have just released last September it's
the software that it's it's not that we
reinvent the wheel and try to create the
simulators that are great out there
there are very good tools like neuronal
nest for example to what to run neuronal
simulations but if you ever use those
tools you will find out that a lot of
these things require very substantial
effort to get them going
so for example with neuron if you want
to run a lot of simulation you have to
basically code from scratch neuron gives
you some nice functionality but you have
to write a lot of code to run your
simulation to tell how you build the
model to tell the software exactly how
to run it in parallel what we provide
here are api's Python wrappers around
these very good tools that basically do
not require much of software expertise
from you you can take our tools you can
build your model using you know a number
of commands you can plug in your own
models in there it will create a
standardized set of files for you they
describe the model and then our
simulators can take in those files and
run them for you so this software has
been released it's here on the github
it's just been an alpha release so it
doesn't even have that much
documentation yet but it's already
functional and it has you know we start
populating some tutorials there so I
really encourage everyone to start
checking it out and let us know what you
think about it we are very happy to help
people to start using it and we'll be
we'll be building it further so this is
really to improve sharing of the model
and you know getting getting people to
run simulations rather than write the
code which has been already written okay
so I'll stop here
thank you very much for your attention
and just want to say this is a very huge
team effort that I've been described it
we have over 300 people now at our
Institute a big team of very dedicated
people working very hard so many thanks
to them for their contributions and to
our founder for the vision encouragement
and support
thank you so I couldn't care well how
many
so the actual number of parameters that
we're optimizing was exactly the same
because in the biophysical model we
built the network model we took the
building blocks which were the models of
individual cells and we didn't change
any of that once the model was built the
only thing that we were optimizing were
synaptic weights and we were optimizing
them as groups so there was like five
cell types and we would say well what is
the connection what what is the weight
from this cell type to all the
excitatory cells for example right and
that gives you something like 20
parameters essentially and that number
that you change it's like it's it's a
number in front of some kind of equation
so you don't change the equation you
don't change the distribution of
synaptic weights you just change their
magnitude by a uniform multiplier and it
was exactly the same in the point you
run more because again we had everything
set in fact the connectivity was exactly
1 to 1 between by physical and point
here and wallows was exactly the same
cells just represented in a different
way and so all you change is these 20
knobs that are the same between the
biophysical and
and other questions seems like
ultimately if you want to show that
you've captured something about the vial
of biology here that that you'd want to
show that you captured something about
this function yep therefore so you can
show you know that you've captured
certain aspects of the statistics of the
activity which is kind of circumstantial
evidence
you know layer further it seems like
between the stuff Geoff is telling us
this morning I think it's sort of
channel Geoff I don't know these two
here but you know that all these details
are incredibly important right and
you're sort of throwing those out and
replacing with kind of a statistical
kind of randomness into and you know you
can show you can get some of the aspects
of the physiology correct but but it
seems like ultimately this is this
button this might be one way of testing
this debate we're having earlier about
you know randomness versus structure and
then if you could take the if you had
sort of you could take the client kind
of connect tommix data you're getting it
right at a very detailed level and
preserve that let's say you do that
preserve that as much as possible and
then compare that to this kind of
statistical replacement and then look at
sort of compare these two is that it is
that in cards I mean is that even doable
or is it so yeah I think this is a
fantastic question and at the heart of
what needs to be done I can say a few
things about that so number one is I
think the answer really will depend on
what you think is important nobody is
going to tell you what is important we
don't know what is important we don't
know if it's the statistics of responses
that let's say you know all cells have
this orientation selectivity because
that's about 0.5 if that is important or
if it's some kind of other very
intricate very specialized parameter
that's important and so until we know
better what to look for
we don't really know and I think we will
not know better it will be a cell you
know reinforcement process where we do
something and models we do something and
experiments we try to look at
and aspects of behavior of perception of
memory and come up with different
observables that will be important to
test and the answer will be different
for different observables so this is
think number one think number two is you
know I think you're exactly right in
this example that you made that we are
in a wonderful position to actually test
how the statistical implementation of
the model will compare with the specific
implementation from biology because once
this electron microscopy datasets are
ready you know with the modeling tools
that we have already now we can just
take that connectome once we have the
actual connectivity matrix you know
saying that cell is connected to so B we
can just take that and plug it in into
the model right away we will have to
come up with some kind of approximation
of what each cell is how you know which
cell types belongs to what
electrophysiology of the cells are and
there will be still a lot of parameters
that are unconstrained from that point
of view but at least we will have the
real connection not the statistical
that's from how we cooked up based on
the literature and we're incomplete data
and will be extremely extremely
interesting to do exactly that and
compare especially because we will have
the Physiol physiology the in vivo
physiology of those exact neurons so I
think that will be like a real moment of
tools for for such models but that comes
with a caveat also that that pubic
millimeter that people are
reconstructing with the associated in
vivo physiology is just one cubic
millimeter it's just the piece of the
brain and as we found out for example in
this exercise with layer 4 the inputs
are immensely important the it really
the activity is going to change very
dramatically depending on what we
provide as an input from the thalamus
it's going to be very different and so
unfortunately when with those millimeter
coupe reconstructed we want well we may
have some idea about exons that come
from the thalamus in that volume and we
might be able to make some kind of smart
predictions but we won't have real
complete diagram of inputs
sells and recurrent connections there is
much more work to do for many years to
come use the models would be no to put
them into my function oriented context
right now that you play now network to
do something but probably but I guess
one has to put it in the market even
more romantic function context than just
to reproduce next ferment like doing
lots of image classification or
something of this type or any you know
syndrome motor control and then see
apparently you have to add to this
speculated learning algorithms way right
but no together with the AMA database no
network models so do you think is this a
reasonable approach and are you moving
this direction yeah I think it's
absolutely very very good approach and
we are moving in that direction I'm not
sure we'll be able to do that with this
sort of model that we develop in our
team will that by physically detailed
model just because it's so expensive but
some of my colleagues who will be here
in the next few months they are doing
exactly that with simpler models and we
are trying to do a mapping call so you
know this work that I described wherever
we replaced by physical cells with point
neuron cells that was done for the
reason the reason that we could have a
cheaper instantiation maybe not as
accurate but cheaper instantiation of
such a model and then we could try so
many different things with those cheaper
instantiations we can make multiple
models of multiple cortical areas and
connect them together or we can try to
test some of the hypotheses and they
include learning rules like you
mentioned so that I totally agree with
you it just has to be done you know
keeping the computation expense in mind
how big are the networks that use the
movie or is there sort of like a minimum
size that you need
for which you can you can replicate the
yeah that's a good good question too we
haven't really looked in it very
systematically
but one thing that I can tell you is
that some of it is constrained by
experimental data by the probabilities
of connections between neurons and the
distance range of this probability of
connection and from death data you
basically realize that unless you
simulate something like several
thousands of neurons at a time you are
missing some missing out on a lot of
connections and a lot of partners that
naturally would be there I can also tell
you that if you put together a few
hundred new ones and connect them with
the probabilities that are coming from
the experiment and with the strands of
connections that come from experiment I
doubt very much that you'll be able to
get that network to behave nicely
probably will be either epileptic of
silent so you know from those couple of
observations I would say a few thousand
to ten thousand neurons is the minimum
that you have to go for although you can
do a lot in terms of so I mean not
really other than that very simplistic
model of background activity that I
showed essentially how the background
activity was working and that models
that we had a process that was sometimes
off and sometimes on and when it's on
that provided some kind of unstructured
additional synaptic input into all the
cells so it's like the simplest possible
way of representing cortical States
which is of course a very complex
phenomena and it includes synaptic
transmission as well as new the new
modulation so we didn't address it very
specifically but we had sort of poor
man's way of represented at least
something and there were some
interesting thing that we fought
for example we were able to find good
agreement between noise collisions and
just overall level of activities in
those two different states compared to
what people reported in the literature
that you know let's say in a up and down
state the the patterns of activities are
somewhat different
there is no learning role the synapses
are static in my model yeah did so
optimization was done manually manually
by by human by human intervention
basically you start with a set of
synapses you tell that based on the
experimental data the synaptic weights
have to be within certain range and then
you keep them within that certain range
but you tweak them by hand and you run
you know hundreds of simulations and you
see what happens and you use your
intuition to get to a regime that is
non-epileptic that's yeah I mean we
didn't do it systematically because that
would be very expensive but interesting
I agree
but we haven't done a systematically
just you know based on intuition that we
gained by doing that exercise it's what
can I say
sensitive but it's not super sensitive
so if you change your synaptic weights
by let's say 1% I would say you probably
are going to get more or less the same
picture if you change it by 5% it may
shift you to a different regime
even the biophysical mall just kind of
higher than the experiments I was
wondering is it because the orientation
selectivity index of actual sales
getting underestimated because like
they're steaming he wasn't optimized in
terms of special frequency of things for
anyone oh is it those numbers from
experiments are really leaving and the
model is really well I would say the
impatient selectivity in the model was
actually pretty close to the experiment
they think is the experiment itself
gives you gives you numbers that are not
you know not always consistent between
experiment and experiment it's like yeah
and also depends on the state of the
animals so these are to expel you know
two sets of experiments where in one
case the animal is anesthetized and the
other case it's awake and that by itself
changes the number so you see so in one
case you get below point three and the
other case you get something like point
five and you know here for the different
excitatory cell types we get something
in between so I'd say you know given how
simplistic the model is I would take
this result to be pretty good but it's
yeah it's not super precise even if you
compare an experiment to experiment and
also it differs for you know we've run
more experiments like this since then
and sometimes you observe things that
are you know slightly inconsistent even
with this picture so it's it's
complicated
all right thank you starting tomorrow
9:30 with Parliament